i'm here in my apartment in shanghai
in the last day supposed the last day of
my lockdown but it looks like it's going
to be extended
and my biggest concern right now is food
i'm running short of everything and i
want to give you a little peek inside my
refrigerator it may not look so bad but
i got i got to tell you a lot of stuff
is pretty old um got milk here the
expiration date is april
first
the bread's expiration date is march
30th and today is april 6. thank god i
still have a little bit of wine because
i think i'm going to need it so the
biggest concern right now for a lot of
people is how to get food
for us um we have to order online
through this one grocery app called ding
dong mai chai basically in the evening
usually after 9 00 pm you go into the
app and see what's available and as you
can see a lot of fruit meat and
vegetables already gone the big problem
seems to be we can't get groceries
delivered to our apartment because
there's a lack of drivers delivering
food in general because of the lockdown
the number of cases contains the rise in
shanghai and jilin province
both areas are struggling with the
economic and personal ramifications of
the lockdowns with food shortages a lack
of medical care and shuttered
manufacturing plants bringing misery to
residents shanghai remains the hot spot
for the current flare despite
indefinitely extending a sweeping
lockdown of his 25 million people
originally intended to be carried out in
two parts the rising number of
infections led to a continuation of the
restrictions in the eastern portion of
the city that were initially expected to
be lifted last week
so one question that i'm getting asked
is why didn't i uh why didn't i i stock
up on more food well well first is you
know we were told that my phase of
lockdown
would last from friday through uh
tuesday
and it's already wednesday uh didn't
know that it was gonna be extended
obviously i could have gotten more meat
and vegetables but even before the
lockdowns it was kind of hard to find
you know i still have a lot of instant
noodles spam and
the odd carrot
[Music]
you